- [Narrator] This is Peter,
and he's a giant anteater.
(playful music)
The giant anteater is
the largest of the four
anteater species, reaching
up to seven feet in length.
Anteaters are edentates,
which is a fancy way
of saying they have no teeth.
But with a tongue that can
reach two feet in length,
eating is never a problem.
In the wild, they enjoy a diet of ants,
termites, grubs, and the occasional fruit.
Here in captivity, Peter chows down
on this insect porridge and yogurt.
Their tongue can flick up to
150 times a minute, letting
them gobble up tens of
thousands of insects each day.
The giant anteater's four-inch claws
and muscular forelegs are
used to tear apart anthills
and termite mounds, but
also to fend off predators
like mountain lions and jaguars.
The species is currently vulnerable
due to over hunting by
humans and habitat loss.
The giant anteater dates
back 25 million years,
so conversation efforts are working hard
to keep Peter and his species around.
This is the giant anteater.
(playful music)